Let's look at the solution for our 1-Bit History Quiz. We have a 1-Bit history
that starts at zero. And two bit counter for each possible history,
all counters start at strong not taken. And the pattern we are trying to predict
is the not taken, not taken, taken, etc. After 100 repetitions of this pattern,
what is the total number of mispredictions that we will have seen?
One way to approach this problem is simply to work through the table like we
have seen before. So we will have our state, the prediction, the outcome, and
whether we are correct. And now we will just work through the outcomes.
The outcomes will be N, N, T, N, N,
T, etc. And of course we will not go through a 100 repetitions of this. Pretty
soon the predictor will start to be very consistent about what it's predicting
in each round of the pattern. The state initially is zero, strong not taken,
strong not taken. The prediction as a result of that will be use 0th counter,
which is saying strong not taken. So the prediction will be not taken.
This agrees with the outcome, so we are correct. Update the predictor. So
the state will be zero because the outcome was not taken. Strong not taken will
be updated with a not taken outcome, so it stays strong not taken, and
the other counter just stays the same. Now the predictor again, will predict not
taken, using zero and strong not taken. And it will again be correct.
So, the history stays at zero, the strong not taken stays at strong not taken,
and the other counter just stays the same. And at this point,
we will again, with the history of zero use this, predict not taken strongly and
be wrong this time. So after one round, we have a single misprediction.
The history will be one now. And the predictor here
will be updated to weak, not taken, because there has been a taken outcome.
And the other predictor just stays the same. Now we will use a history of one,
to index say strong not taken. So the outcome will be not taken and
be correct. Next, we will keep the strong not taken here.
The other counter stays the same. The history becomes zero because of this, and
we will use a history of zero to index into the weak not taken state, and
thus predict not taken again. Again we are correct in our decision.
Next, the history stays zero, because the decision was not taken.
The update of the weak not taken goes back to the strong not taken,
because the decision was not taken, the other counter stays the same.
And using the history of zero, we will index and use this counter.
This counter says strong not taken, so we will predict not taken.
This will disagree with the taken prediction, so we will have a misprediction.
This concludes round two. As you can see, at the end of round two,
we have the same state that we had at the end of round one.
So now, pretty much what happened in round two will repeat more times.
Overall, in the 100 repetitions of this, in each repetition we have a single
misprediction. So, the correct answer is that we have 100 mispredictions, or
one-third of our decisions are wrong. As you can see,
the 1-bit history predictor is not a great predictor for this type of a pattern.